-Former President Trump secretly
tested positive for COVID
before coming into contact
with more than 500 people,
including Joe Biden,
at their first debate.
Meanwhile, Republicans
and Fox News
are suggesting a new variant
of the coronavirus
is a liberal hoax.
For more on this,
it's time for A Closer Look.
♪♪
Despite receding to his hideout
in Mar-a-Lago,
where he's occasionally glimpsed
giving horrible toasts
on blurry cell phone footage
like a Florida swamp ghost
who haunts weddings.
Donald Trump remains under
multiple serious investigations.
There's the investigation into
his election meddling
in Atlanta,
the investigation
of his business in New York,
and the congressional
investigation
of the insurrection
he stoked on January 6th.
Plus, I don't know, like,
a dozen other investigations
I've stopped
keeping track of.
He's probably still got
a pending case
over the time he left
Air Force One
parked next to a fire hydrant
in Times Square.
[Imitating Trump] Officer, I was
just running in real quick
to grab some M&Ms
from the M&M Store.
We love -- We love M&Ms,
don't we, folks?
We love them.
They've got your red one,
the nervous orange one.
and of course,
the sexy --
the sexy green M&M.
Women want to be her and men --
men want to be with her.
I met her backstage
in '86, Jon Bovi concert.
I said, Jon Bovi.
I meant Bon Jovi.
I flubbed it.
You know, there's one thing
we know about the Donald --
I admit when I made a mistake.
When I get it wrong,
I own up right away.
I met her at a Bon Jovi concert.
[Normally] And yet, even with
those various...
[laughing] investigations
intensifying,
Trump is still
freely confessing
to crimes
from past investigations.
Over the weekend,
he essentially confessed
to obstructing
the Russia investigation
by bragging about the fact
that he fired
then-FBI Director James Comey
to protect himself.
-Don't forget, I fired Comey.
Had I not fired Comey,
you might not be talking
to me right now
about a beautiful book
of 4 years
at the White House,
and we'll see
about the future.
The future's going
to be very interesting.
But I fired Comey --
that whole group --
and now that group
is coming back again?
I mean, it's not believable.
-He was definitely expecting
his interviewer
to jump in there
with a, "Good point, sir."
Trump always forgets that even
his most fervent supporters
sometimes can't follow
what he's talking about.
I also like the Trump literally
starts a confession by saying,
"Don't forget."
He's like a defendant
jumping up in court, saying,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Before you return
that murder weapon
to evidence,
maybe, uh,
dust it for prints."
Trump supporters
always want to know
why people can't stop
talking about his crimes
when he can't stop talking
about his crimes.
In fact, Trump was so intent
on reminding everyone
he obstructed justice
during the Russia investigation
that he again came back to it
later during the interview,
out of nowhere.
-I was going to say before,
if I didn't fire Comey,
they were looking to take down
the President
of the United States
if I didn't fire him.
And some people said,
"He made a mistake
when he fired Comey."
And now those same people said
it was most incredible,
instinctual moves
that they've ever seen.
Because I wouldn't --
I might be here with you.
Perhaps we'll be talking
about something else.
But I don't think I could have
survived if I didn't fire him
because it was like
a hornet's nest.
When I fired him,
they all went crazy.
-What are you talking about?
Even I don't ramble that much to
my therapist.
I'm just kidding.
I don't have a therapist.
I have you guys.
A therapist --
A therapist would never...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, it's cheaper.
A therapist would never
put up with this many tangents.
"I think, Seth,
it would just be more helpful
if we dug into your childhood."
Yeah, sure, sure, sure, sure.
But what if Al Pacino
had been in Dune?
Like what would...
What would that even sound like?
[Imitating Al Pacino]
Alright, let's go.
The House of Atreides
will bring peace to Arrakis.
Oh, yeah.
[Normally] I genuinely wonder
if --
I genuinely wonder
if even Trump fans
are capable of understanding
what he's saying,
or if his stream
of consciousness rambling
is just a soothing way
for them to fall asleep.
Because I will say,
I would definitely listen to
one of those nature sound CDs
with Trump's voice
to help me doze off.
[ Nature sounds play ]
-I never understood wind.
You know, I know windmills
very much.
They're noisy.
They kill the birds.
You want to see
a bird graveyard?
Go under a windmill someday.
You'll see more birds
than you've ever seen
ever in your life.
-Now, the congressional
investigation into Trump
for the January 6th insurrection
has been impeded,
in part by the fact
that some of his cronies
have refused to cooperate,
like his former Chief of Staff,
Mark Meadows,
who cited executive privilege
and said he would remain
loyal to Trump
and defy a congressional
subpoena,
asking him to spill
any Trump secrets he might have.
-Former Trump Chief of Staff
Mark Meadows,
who also happens to be
a former member of Congress,
he was a no show today,
despite the 1/6 committee's
demand
that he appear
for a deposition,
10:00 AM sharp.
Meadows has also invoked
Trump's claim
of executive privilege.
-There you go. Mark Meadows
is claiming executive privilege.
His interactions
with the president
are private and confidential,
and as a loyal friend and ally,
he would never
betray that sacred --
I'm sorry, what's that?
He wrote a book?
Then he got
paid money for it.
Is it called
Home Gardening Tips,
But No Secrets
About Donald Trump?
It's not?
Well, what's in it?
Juicy details
about all his private
interactions with Donald Trump?
But what about
executive privilege?
Alright, you know what?
I really feel like
you guys got to explain
this stuff to me
before the show.
I mean,
even Wally's confused.
Yeah.
Yeah, you're right,
the clip packages
always do a good job
of explaining stuff.
The only problem
with the clip packages
is they never have
any Al Pacino.
Alright.
Whatever, let's roll it.
-Donald Trump tested positive
for coronavirus
3 days before his first debate
against Joe Biden
on September 29th, 2020.
This stunning revelation
is in a new book
by former White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows
that was obtained by
The Guardian --
a positive test the country
never knew about.
Despite the positive test,
Trump attended an indoor event
with gold star
military families.
Two days later,
on Tuesday, the 29th,
Chris Wallace at Fox says Trump
was not tested at the debate
because he arrived late
and they allowed him on stage
because they were relying
on the honor system.
Later that week,
on Thursday, the 1st,
Trump officially
tested positive,
according to his doctor --
-Who-ah.
-Oh.
First of all, I like
that Trump's aides
won't talk to Congress,
but if they get a book deal,
they'll tell the entire world
the worst [bleep]
they can possibly think of.
"I'll never testify before
Congress about my good friend
and loyal steward
Donald Trump,
a man I admire and look up to,
who I would never betray.
You'll just have to read my book
titled Trash Can Human Being."
So it turns out,
Trump tested positive for COVID
before a presidential debate
with Joe Biden
and kept it a secret.
Although in retrospect,
I feel like maybe we should
have known from that debate
that he had something,
based on his performance.
It was either COVID or rabies.
-I'll ask Joe.
-[Stammering]
-[Speaking incoherently]
-No! Hey, Mr. President.
No, Mr. President.
No, no. Go ahead.
No, no, no, Mr. President.
-3 1/2 million, Joe.
-Mr. President --
-Who-ah.
-No, Mr. President.
-Go ahead.
-Can I be honest?
It's a very important --
-Try to be honest,
it'd be good for you.
-He stood up --
-No.
-Oh, good.
So not only did he have COVID,
but his mouth was open
the entire time.
It's like he was
trying to spread it.
If you had a 4K TV,
you could actually see
the coronavirus particles
coming out of his mouth.
Trump secretly tested positive
for COVID, didn't tell anyone.
And then he went to an event
with military families
and a presidential debate,
knowing he was
potentially spreading COVID.
In fact, The Washington Post
reported...
He's like the Johnny Appleseed
of COVID.
Now, people keep saying
that Trump looked terrible
and we should have known
he had COVID.
But I mean, when does he,
you know, not look terrible?
I mean, look at this. Are we
supposed to be able to tell?
I mean, look at these pictures.
When was the COVID?
He was never exactly
the picture of health, you know.
You know how at the end
of pill commercials,
they quickly list
all the possible side effects.
They should just replace that
with a photo of Trump.
He always looked like
a patient on "House"
who gets saved
at the last minute
by some unorthodox treatment.
"Donald, there's only
one way to save you.
We're gonna to hook you up --"
[ Laughs ] I'm sorry.
Donald -- [ Laughs ]
OK, OK. "Donald, there's
only one way to save you.
We're going to hook up
your heart to a pig's heart
and have you swap brains."
Suffice it to say, it's a relief
to know he's no longer in charge
as we face the prospect
once again of rising cases,
a winter surge, and now,
a new,
possibly even more transmissible
variant.
Now, thankfully,
scientists, being the cautious,
measured, people that they are,
have given it a totally benign
and not at all terrifying name.
[Echoing] The Omicron Variant.
[ Lightning crashes ]
[ Witch cackles ]
"The Omicron Variant"
sounds like a paperback
I read at my grandma's house
because there was
[bleep] else to do.
No, Grandma, I don't want
to read your stories.
What the [bleep[ is this?
Seriously,
the Omicron variant?
I thought scientists were
supposed to be mild-mannered,
analytical types
who don't want you to panic.
I get that they're just going
by the Greek alphabet,
but the Greek alphabet
is very scary.
I propose we start
naming the variants
after popular child stars
of the '90s.
I would just panic less
if Fauci was on TV,
telling us about
the Lipnicki variant.
"You know, the Lipnicki variant,
much like the actor
it's named after,
it's infectious."
Anyway, Omicron,
a.k.a. Haley Joel Omicron --
see, it works --
is already here,
and yet Republicans on Fox News
are dismissing it
as some sort of liberal hoax,
with one Republican calling it
"the midterm election variant,"
another saying Joe Biden
wants to make COVID
the forever pandemic,
and Fox News hosts suggesting
Biden just came up with it
to help him politically.
-The emergence of
the new COVID variant
is sparking a fresh round
of conspiracy theories.
Former White House doctor
turned MAGA congressman
Ronny Jackson tweeted, quote,
"Here comes the MEV --
the Midterm Election Variant."
-Democrats are already using
this to jam through
their pro-lockdown,
anti-freedom agenda,
but we're not surprised.
A new scary variant
is another liberal cover up
for Joe Biden's ongoing
and many failures.
And maybe that might help them
in the upcoming
midterm elections.
-It's always a new variant.
-And you can always --
you'll count on a variant about
every October, every 2 years.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, I think it's gonna -- Yep.
You know,
you're probably right.
-However...
-They could speed up.
The variants
can come more quickly.
-We're going to need
a new variant here.
-Alright. First of all,
I hate to nitpick here,
but that's not how you mime
holding a phone.
See, if you're pretending
to hold a phone,
you hold it like this.
Your hand isn't the phone.
The phone is in your hand.
Like, for example, if I were
to mime taking a phone call,
I would -- I would do this.
"Hello? President of NBC?
Uh-huh.
Yes, this is Seth Meyers.
[ Gasps ]
I've used up my show's entire
tangent budget for the year?!
Which year? 2022?!"
Anyway, back to Fox News.
Are you out of
your [bleep] mind?
You think anyone wants
this pandemic to keep going?
You think that's good
for Democrats politically?
Everyone is miserable. No one
wants this thing to keep going.
We all desperately want life
to go back to normal.
I can't believe I'm saying this,
but I give anything to be
on a packed "F" train
high fiving rats
and reconnecting with the dude
who insists on bringing his bike
on during rush hour.
I miss that guy.
Why do you have a bike
on the train, though?
Why are you bringing
one mode of transportation
onto another,
slower mode of transport?
Just ride the bike to work.
You'll beat us all there.
We're all still dealing with
a once-in-a-century catastrophe
that has resulted
in mass suffering,
and we have one party
that either thinks it's a hoax
or actively tries to spread it
to as many people as possible.
We all desperately want
to get back to normal.
The difference is,
one side is a bunch of proposals
for how to get there,
and all the other side
can say is...
-"Yabba-dabba-doo."
-In what context
did he say that?
This has been A Closer Look.
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver,
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.